North Korea is demanding the u.s.
removed Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
from talks over north of the North
Korean nuclear program the country's
foreign minister said overnight they
want to deal with someone who is quote
more careful and mature North Korea also
said it test-fired a new tactical guided
weapon that's the regime's
first such test since President Trump
met with North Korean leader Kim jong-un
earlier this year Ben Tracy is following
these developments from Beijing good
morning North Korea has not provided
many details about what exactly this
weapon is that they've tested but we do
know it is not a ballistic missile it
does not appear to be a weapon that is
capable of striking the United States
now state media in North Korea reports
that North Korean leader Kim jong-un
supervised the test and says the weapon
demonstrated the ability to deliver a
powerful warhead North Korea has not
publicly announced a weapons test since
last November but it appears it is
ramping up its military capabilities
state media released these photos on
wednesday of kim overseeing a flight
drill conducted by the country's air
force now there have also been signs of
activity at North Korean nuclear and
missile production sites this could be a
sign of Kim's frustration with the
diplomacy between him and president
Trump the two failed to reach a
denuclearization agreement at their
summit in Vietnam in February now
president Trump has been defending the
lack of progress at those summits by
saying that North Korea has not been
testing weapons that is now harder to
say Kim jong-un is expected to soon meet
with another world leader Russia's
Vladimir Putin for CBS this morning Ben
Tracy Beijing